皆さん！ねるねるねるねって知ってますでしょうか。
はいこちらです。まー知育菓子といったらこれ的なこともあると思う。
まあ30周年か！　おいらが生まれる前からずっとあるんですね...
これ作るときですねー、唯一準備しなきゃいけないものがある。それは何か！　・・水！
唯一我々がねるねるねるねにかんしょうできるタイミングとしてはここしかない！　そう！水を必要とします！
そういうことです
ねるねるねるねるはただの知育菓子ではない！
これはふつうに一般的にひかれたレールをただ走るだけの知育菓子ではないということを
皆さんお気づきいただけただろうか。
ねるねるねるねはこの1.2.3のこの粉を「バンっ！」っとふって、水「バンっ！」ってかけて作れるものでは
ないんですよ！
そう
水を入れるというタイミング、でもこの中に水ははいっていない！
つまり水は自分で準備しなきゃ
いけない！
我々には選択肢が生まれるということでございます！
我々の周りにはありとあらゆる水分が存在する
つまり！
この知育菓子は何を言いたいというと
敷かれたレールの上を走るな
そういうメッセージがあるんですよ！
たぶんないです...
たぶんないです..たぶんないですけどもー
ふつうに水を入れても作れるんですけども〜
これひょっとしたら
水を他のに変えて作れることが可能ではないか？
そこを含めてわたしは知育菓子と思いたい！　　　　（パチパチパチパチ）
（フォーー）ありがとう、ありがとう
水以外のいろんなものを準備しました！
これはふつうにおいしっしょ
水を使う場面の水分を水ではないものでやってみたら
果たしてどうなるのか
ひょっとしたらー
水よりも美味しく作れるかもしれない
そうなれば
みなさんはもう
水を入れる必要が...ない！
そう！今！
ねるねるねるねは新たな時代に突入する！
ではいこう
はいでは作っていきましょう
お水...飲みかけで申し訳ない..
でもおいらもう最近おかし食べ過ぎてるからさ
なるべく水見たいのを飲もうとしています
あーできるかな僕
水って言ってもここに入れるだけ！なんですよね実際使う量
っていうのは
ポイントは果たしてこれに意味があるかどうかってトコですよね...実際
あーover flow
おーぷるぷるぷるるん！
ひとまずこれをどうするかだ！
え、え、まじどうすればいい？？
「丸い形のコーナーに入れます」..はい
おー
やばい色がw
めっちゃかんたんやん
わーすげー色が変わってきた
3番を隣のトレイに入れると..
とりあえずここにあるドリンク分全部作ってー
最後に全部順番に食べていこうと思います。
ではつくってこーーーー
わー泡がすごい...
うわー、ちょっとうすぎたなくなったよー
コーラ自体に色の色素があるから
ちょっと色が変わっちゃいますね、やっぱり
2の粉いれます
さあこれで果たして何色になるかが　.....わーーー
でもちがうわ
後で比較してみるんんですけども、本家よりやっぱちょっと
次お茶だよー
はい...あれなんか色おかしい！
そんなことはない?
女の子と手繋ぎてぇわ
お茶はこんな感じですね！あんまり仕合がない感じですね
つぎはなっちゃんん！！です！！
ok very good .....やっ！
食べまちゅよー...んーよしよしー
あーーーーー
結局みんな同じなのかなー
色の変化が顕著にみられん
まあ..いい。はいなっちゃんこんな感じです！
うめぇ
おいしい牛乳です
ここからはちょっとわりとおふざけじゃないっすよ
いやおふざけですけど
ここからは完全色が入ってますからね
よっしゃ
牛乳ってやっぱなんか特殊なんすよね
やっぱり
あーーーーー
硬いぞ
うわ、なんか、あれ！なんか硬いぞ...
今牛乳心許しましたね
最初はやっぱり嫌がってたんすけど
実はいやよいやよも好きのうち
なパターンですね
ん、あーーーーーーーーーーー
同じだわ、
なんなの！結局全部同じ説あるぅ！？これぇ
キッコーマンの醤油です
だれが！？だれが！？ねるねるねるねを醤油でつくろうか？
風味が出て美味しくなるパターンもありえる
お楽しみだぁい！
まて...全然かたまぬぞぉ！
やばい、、え、まってゴリゴリに固まる
えーーーーー
まってww、すごいなぁ
すごい！全然違う今までのと
や、この粉を入れてどうチェンジするかですよ！
あー断固としてやばい、これ
というわけで、お醤油はこんな感じでございます
つぎはビールだよ
子供は飲んじゃダメだよ
うまぁい！！！
んははww 主旨が変わってくるな
お酒はどうでるか
おつまみと一体化した新型ビールみたいな
まー色はいつも通りですね
ビールってそんなでも色がないイメージだなぁ
いつも通り多分ピンクになるのではないでしょうか。
ふつうにピンクだね
スピリタス！96%アルコール
こんなのでねるねるねるね作る人はまずいない！
うわーやばいやばい、アルコールでお酒作るのと同じですからね
いきます
おいらも緊張するんだけど、はい
うわー、ってかスースーする
やば、早くまぜよ
あれぇ
あれ、あれぇ、あれ？
しゃ、しゃ、しゃ、ええ！　シャカシャカ、シャクシャクシャク
ひょっとして揮発しちゃったぁ！？
え、やばい、どうしようこれ
揮発性があるから....ちょい追加
すぐまぜないと
もう、すぐすぐ、すぐまぜる
すぐまぜる、あーいいんじゃないかぁ
もうもう！すぐ2番行きます
いけ..
よし大丈夫！もうものにしろ！
えーもうシャクシャクやん....
えー
すげぇなー、えることすらできませんでした
ぱっと見こんな感じでございます〜
まー水がふつうバージョン
コーラ、ちょっとうすぎたない..
おーいお茶、まーふつう
オレンジジュース、まーふつう
牛乳、まーふつう
お醤油、....
ビール、まーふつう
スピリタス、.....うん
結局大事なのは味ですからねぇ〜
じゃあまずはノーマルから食べていきます
ふわふわだなぁ、これ絶対ふつうにおいしいでしょ
いただきます
うん、うん、うまい！
言うことなし！
うん、ん、うめぇ〜
次、コーラです
いただきます
うまい！
ちょっとシュワっと感がちゃんと残っています
ひょっとしたら水で作るよりおいしいかもしれません
うん...うまいこれ！　　コーラでねるねるねるねはあり、です、たぶん
じゃあ次、お茶行きます
あーーーー
いただきます
うん。わるくはない！
（咳）わるくはない
あのもし水がないかたいたら多分お茶で代用しても問題ないと思います
ではつぎなっちゃんいきます
いただきます！
あーあるようでないっすね〜
牛乳です
みるきー　いや伸びすぎじゃね？
ねるねるねるねってこんな伸びるもんだっけ？
伸びすぎて食べづらいわ
あーーーむずいわ！可もなく不可もなく水の方がよし！
つぎぃ！
つぎは醤油です
いただきます
ああああああーー
つぎはビールです、いただきます
これ..ないわ..
アルコール90%のねるねるねるね、こんなの見たことない
うわあああっっ！！！！ああっ！
あっあっああああああ
うわあああああああああああああああああああ
うわぁ！うわぁ！うわっ！うわぁ！うわぁ！うわっ！うわぁ！うわぁ！うわっ！
ちょっとやばい...コーラコーラ
はっはっはっはっはっはっはっはーーーーー
コーラうま..